This video was made possible by Skillshare.
Learn anything, including how I make these
videos, for free for two months by going to
Skl.sh/wendover.
This is Indiana, and this is Scotland.
Both have a similar number of inhabitants,
a similar size, and a similar population density.
But here’s Indiana’s public transportation
system, and here’s Scotland’s.
You want to get to Cupar, a town of 9,000
30 miles from the capital?
That’ll take you 55 minutes on a train that
leaves every 30 minutes or an hour and 40
minutes on a bus that leaves every 40.
You want to get to Anderson, a town of 50,000
30 miles from Indiana’s capital?
Well, you’re out of luck.
The only option is the car.
Antiquated technology, safety concerns, crumbling
infrastructure, and nonexistence—it’s
not hard to argue that the US public transportation
network is just not good.
Vast swaths of the US have no option but to
drive because the alternative just is not
there.
This has consequences on the environment,
on economic mobility, on where people live,
the consequences of America’s lack of solid
public transportation almost defines American
culture.
But it wasn’t always like this.
The United States once had the best public
transportation system in the world.
It was a the admiration of countries worldwide
and an essential factor allowing for the successful
western expansion of the country.
It all started with this—the horsecar.
Now, there were urban transportation systems
before these horse drawn trams came along,
but they weren't cheap and they weren’t
fast.
Roads generally weren’t paved and there
just wasn’t the economic demand for high
frequency service because these carriages
were rarely faster than walking.
But on rails, these horsecars were fast and
one horse could pull a full load of passengers
thanks to the rails.
In its heyday, there were over 6,000 miles
of horsecar lines in the US.
In comparison, the combined mileage of every
tram, subway, light rail, and commuter rail
system in the US nowadays is 5,416.
In 1880, 50 million people lived in the US.
Today, over 320 million.
Around the turn of the century, many of those
horsecar systems were electrified.
There were then 11,000 miles of streetcar
track nationwide.
The systems were absolutely everywhere.
Even tiny towns like Bangor, Maine and Berlin,
New Hampshire had streetcars.
So what happened?
How did the US go from having 11,000 miles
of streetcar to 200?
How did the US go from having solid public
transportation in towns big and small across
the country to how it is today?
The decline of the streetcar began just after
the turn of the century.
That was when the automobile came around.
By 1920, the car was starting to get to an
attainable price-point for the everyday individual.
That was the real threat for the streetcar—not
cars, but economical cars.
The streetcar received another blow in 1929—the
great depression.
There were fewer people with jobs which meant
fewer people who needed to commute and fewer
people who had the money to pay for transport
so many lines were just not profitable anymore
and closed.
But then the streetcar received a stay of
execution—World War Two.
You see, during World War Two, the US had
the lowest unemployment rate in history—as
low as 1.2%.
There were tons of factory jobs to support
the war so practically everyone who wanted
a job had a job.
That meant there were tons more people now
going to and from work, and, even better for
the streetcar, there were rations going on
on rubber and gas which diminished the popularity
of the car.
But something else was going on through all
of that.
Something more sinister.
Sometime in the 1920s, automobile technology
became advanced enough that the bus became
cheaper to operate than the streetcar.
Streetcars cost very little to power, but
they do require a lot of infrastructure from
overhead lines to track.
Buses were more flexible and required almost
no infrastructure.
And the bus had some powerful friends, the
automobile companies, or more specifically,
General Motors.
General Motors went and bought dozens of small
streetcar companies across the nation and
turned them into bus companies.
They removed hundreds of miles of track across
the US and supported other companies doing
the same, but its not like they didn’t have
a good reason to do this.
These streetcars were not economically advantageous.
Buses were faster, cheaper, and at the time,
they were the modern and fresh transportation
method that the public wanted.
Nearly every streetcar system nationwide was
replaced with a bus system.
In addition, the streetcar companies were
almost all commercial so if and when they
failed, many local governments set up public,
subsidized bus companies.
So that’s how transportation got bad, but
why did it stay bad?
Well, mostly because of the car.
America is the country of the car.
It grew up as the car grew up and so its cities
were built for cars.
Think Dallas, Phoenix, Los Angeles—you can’t
survive in these cities without a car.
Remember, the United States is centered around
the idea of personal freedom.
With a car, you can go anywhere at anytime,
so politically, cars have historically been
associated with the idea of personal freedom.
Just like the Republican party votes to have
strong national defense, allow gun ownership,
and preserve small government in order to
promote personal freedom, they have always
worked to promote the usage and ownership
of cars.
This means they often voted in favor of subsidies
helping the auto industry, most often in the
form of indirect subsidies lowering the cost
of gas.
Now, that was fine when cities were small,
highways were new, gas was cheap, and climate
change wasn’t even a concept, but that’s
not the case anymore.
Cities are just of a size where they literally
cannot support their entire population driving.
You can’t fit more road infrastructure in
many cites, but you can fit more public transportation.
Cars were available to the common American
much earlier than the common European, so
the US set road policies early that allowed
for large, smooth, well-functioning roads.
While the US was building its magnificent
roads, Europe was building their public transportation
systems.
The high car usage in the US even has to do
with zoning.
You see, European cities tend to have less
strict zoning laws which allow for businesses
and housing to intermingle.
The US zones its cities much more strictly.
Houses are next to houses and businesses are
next to businesses which means that the distances
between houses and shops in the US is much
greater.
Therefore, Americans have to go further more
often.
The most demonstrative fact is how the two
places approach parking.
In the US, zoning laws specify a minimum number
of parking spaces per building.
In Europe, the laws specify a maximum number
of parking spaces.
The three cities with the three lowest car-ownership
rates in the US all have something in common.
Boston, New York, and DC, are all old, rather
compact cities with decent public transportation
systems.
Since they were cities before the car, they’re
built much more like the European cities that
have such good public transportation systems
today.
Simplified, public transportation gets worse
as you go further west since western cities
are newer.
But here’s the most important sentence of
this entire video: access to transportation
is the single most important factor in an
individual’s ability to escape poverty.
That is not a subjective claim, that is a
fact that emerged from a Harvard study.
Someone who lives right by a subway stop is
astronomically more likely to find a high-paying
job than someone who doesn’t have a way
to get around.
Individuals in poverty generally live in poor
neighborhoods with few job opportunities,
but with reliable, accessible, and inexpensive
public transportation these individuals can
get all across their city to where the jobs
are.
So, a good way to evaluate the effectiveness
of a public transportation system is by how
well it serves the poor.
DC, for example, does a good job of this.
The poorest neighborhoods have the greatest
proportion of their residents within a 10-minute
walk of a metro station while the richest
neighborhoods have the smallest proportion.
Hand-in-hand with their move back into the
cities, millennials are shunning cars.
Car ownership among young people is at historic
lows and the urban youth is relying more and
more on public transport.
Some cities like, Portland, Kansas City, Detroit,
and DC are turning back to streetcars.
Done right, streetcars can drive huge increases
in economic development.
They’re more of a symbol of modernization
that entices residents, developers, and businesses
to areas.
Portland, for example, has had an estimated
$5 billion in extra economic development thanks
to its streetcar.
New streetcar systems are being built all
across the US in cities like Milwaukee and
Oklahoma city since they’re finally making
money again—not from their fares, but from
the jobs brought by their existence.
People didn’t want them a century ago, but
streetcars finally make sense again.
Public transportation is instrumentally important
to the success of cities.
You can almost be sure that a good city will
have good public transportation and a bad
city will have bad public transportation.
Public transportation increases economic mobility,
decreases carbon footprints, and increases
economic development so the only question
is, why not build more of it?
One of the most common requests I receive
is for a behind-the-scenes video and I’ve
finally made one.
I’ve partnered up with Skillshare to post
it on their platform.
The course is mainly geared to people who
already do or want to create their own videos
but it should be interesting for anyone.
If you’re not interested in that in particular,
Skillshare has over 16,000 classes about pretty
much anything and everything which you can
watch from anywhere including when you’re
offline by using their IOS or Android apps.
An annual membership gives you unlimited access
to their classes for less than $10/month,
but the first 500 people to sign up over at
Skl.sh/wendover can learn whatever they want
on Skillshare for free for their first two
months including my behind-the-scenes course
which is also linked in the description.